[Music]
hey guys and thanks for tuning into eg
live I'm Katie Krauss and Aaron Carter
is here so excited about this today your
first album in 15 years drums on Friday
ok it's called love which is perfect
because it's Valentine's Day but are you
nervous are you anxious are you excited
really all of that stuff like check
check check
nervous excited anxious you know I'm
just looking forward to you know seeing
fans singing it and performing it and
you know people being able to relate to
the topic of discussion in my album love
so what do you want people to take away
after listening from start to finish I
would say that to just really appreciate
yourself and when you feel like
something's not right to get out of it
and have the strength to get out of it
so that was my problem with like the
last couple of relationships that I was
in and I really want to understand no I
I really will always want to hold on
yeah and you know I'm a big believer and
forgiveness and Jesus Christ you know be
very forgiving but sometimes you really
just you gotta take a look at the
situation in your in and decided whether
that's good for you and leading
sometimes can be really painful yeah and
I want to get into that but I also want
to remind you guys if you're just tuning
in Aaron Carter is here talking all
about his new album if you have
questions comments make sure to send
them in we're gonna answer them right to
your lovely iPad but a lot of the songs
on there are about relationships as you
mentioned I mean it's a perfect song
title what have you learned about love
in the past year what have I learned not
enough cuz I'm single maybe a good thing
though right
it might I don't know I don't really
like being single but it's it's going on
almost
being single and it's cool I'm learning
things about myself I guess I don't know
I like being in relationships I like
being in love yeah and I'm not rushing
to jump in to just like the first thing
that I feel like is great you know
especially not people like be a mini a
messaging me like like I don't do that I
want to be real people it's funny that
you bring that up because I literally
wanted to know how does Aaron Carter
find someone are you on dating apps all
right so what what is the secret are you
opposed to right I mean you're not gonna
do dm's anymore you know I do I'm not
gonna do dm's
I mean I just it's gonna be hard yeah
it's it's it's definitely difficult but
you know I'm like a timing person so and
coincidence I don't know I don't know I
believe in those kind of things you know
maybe leading me to somebody in a
different way than what I normally have
been used to doing so I dated my backup
dancer and then this girl was a
photographer who DM me on Instagram and
then I just I don't have very good luck
Wow what do your dance like what do they
look like yes
like who is lighting in there a bunch of
strangers just they're just people I
don't know I mean there's I mean I just
don't know I just don't know them I I'm
very I don't know
reclusive with relationships you know I
don't like to do they have too many yeah
but it's a mess it's not any fun no it's
not fun no a little bit it was like 10
years ago for like the first year you
know yeah I'm 30 now this is not
realistic for me are you a pursuer or do
you like to be pursued um I don't know I
pursued and then I I don't know I think
I'm gonna go for being the pursuer okay
the one that you're looking for it yeah
well you have a song on there it's
called hard to love and you say that
you're hard to love because you love so
hard so is that maybe one of the best
lessons that you have learned
love that I'm hard to love no is that
your it's maybe too much and anymore
resentful is not it's not all all the
girl's fault you know like I have a role
I play too you know so like I'm not
always perfect so I don't know what do
you responsibility for what I know you
my god I I don't know not being the best
guy I could be in a relationship but I
feel like you've gone through a pretty
difficult year I mean you went to rehab
you worked on yourself a lot do you feel
like now you're in a place like what do
you want out of a relationship moving
forward well the first one I must start
with is myself yeah having a good
relationship and and that was the whole
process of going through the treatment
and stuff last year I mean I was so
stressed and getting through that I was
a winner in there 115 pounds that came
out a hundred and sixty pounds right so
that was like pretty awesome for me and
I don't know just you know that's what I
learned in treatment was like you know
to love yourself before you could really
get into any other relationships and
stuff no I'm gonna start by doing that
and I think this is a good year for that
yeah and you know but that doesn't mean
I'm not gonna keep my my heart open to
love yeah and if it happens and I'm
gonna pursue it heavily you know yeah
the best I can with it I want to get
back to that but I also want to talk
about the song on your album called the
champion mm-hmm about your dad yeah what
was it like to sort of tap into that
emotionally oh my god it was so tough
like writing and writing the song and
but once I got to like the microphone
and I started singing it it just came
out really quickly and it was very easy
to do and there's a lot of passion
behind you it's about my father you know
he was a professional boat racer and he
never lost a race so I called the song
champion he also when I was like four
years old I drowned in a swimming pool
daddy saved my life so drowning and
running in the memories remembering the
day you saved my life pulled me out of
tragedy I'm drawn to the dark but I see
your light so the reason why
that's because when I when I drowned I
remember going through like this very
vivid like experience right and seeing
like some sort of afterlife or something
and I remember seeing myself as a baby
looking towards like there was like a
black and a white light and I was like
looking towards the black then I was you
know resuscitated by my father so it's
crazy yeah what do ya say what do you
think he would think of the journey that
you're on today do you ever think about
that
no no but no I'm going to say no no no
it's good it's good
I think my dad would be very proud of me
maybe not so proud of some of the other
dumb things that I've done so yeah I
mean he was a very instrumental you know
person in my life and was a very good
rock for me and you know he's a very
hard man military policeman style father
so like you know I grew up with a lot of
a lot more discipline than I think
people think I would have had really
yeah I remember last time we talked to
you you told me that you were at like a
house party with your mom when you were
11 so it's surprising oh yeah probably
was no I know my dad and like my dad was
very I don't know my dad and my mom were
very protective of my oppa me like when
I went on the road I had a security
guard it was outside my door whole night
so I couldn't invite any girls you know
smart yeah how did his loss affect the
family dynamic
well I feel like it brought us any
closer unfortunately but I don't know
yeah the dynamic of my family is very
like in its own category it's it's very
strange I mean the industry took a toll
on our family it you know money coming
in so fast and in not growing up with
money like my parents didn't have money
like when when I grew up we were we were
poor like we didn't really have money so
and then once we got all that to get
changed a lot of the personalities and
yeah people in the family started
developing heavy personas and you know
so I really
you know the industry kind of tear apart
my family but you know being in the news
and stuff like that so sometimes it's
really sad to think about but do you
feel like that's you that you had a sort
of adopt a certain persona because
you've been in the industry since you
were literally ten years old yeah for me
actually I never really wanted to
develop any sort of persona or put on
any sort of like you know mask because
of those reasons yeah so I saw those
kind of things and then I wanted to be
able to transcend from any of the you
know shortcomings up you know family
might have had growing up you mentioned
being in the news do you and Nick ever
talk about the headlines that are out
there and no no not really no I mean I
think it's just a part of our our
routine oh yeah is that and Nick and I
never really talked about anything to do
with the business like nothing that's
gonna be kind of nice though I wouldn't
actually is yeah yeah brotherly check
it's always a brotherly checking yes
yeah never we never have those
conversations about stuff or like what
we're striving to do in the industry and
anything like that so does he like any
music at least you talk about that oh
yeah yeah yeah Nick Nick likes the music
I'm not gonna lie yeah alright he tried
to buy fool's gold off of me went right
in the very beginning I purchased it on
iTunes of course I did we're gonna take
a few questions before we get back to to
these guys uh Renee says Aaron you are
so cute happy Valentine's Day
Oh Corey says you look so great and
healthy how are you feeling these days
how am I feeling I'm feeling excited
healthy happy I put a lot out there you
know for people to see last year and it
was um it was kind of hard to do yeah I
mean doctor is on his TV I don't know I
got to this point where I was like okay
I've done too much I gotta back off a
little bit like I was gonna say do you
regret putting so much out there that
that may be one the one time you've ever
heard me really say I have some regrets
and maybe that might be one of my
regrets
yeah well I mean it is what it is like
you know I I'm blessed with my health
I'm I'm a healthy man that's that's very
important to me mm-hmm you know moving
forward I want to be with
be a good father and be healthy you said
that a lot that you want to be a good
father that you want to have kids that
you want to get married one day
how has your this past year sort of
shaped that or enhance that or has it
well I'm going through certain things
that are really challenging when like
the rehab stuff going to be had getting
arrested all this stuffing so I think
that you know it's it's all a testament
to my character building building my
character as a man so I'm learning from
the really tough things and and still
pushing forward with my dreams and my
passions and pursuing them and not
letting anything really get in the way
yeah so but I think though just every
single thing in my life I take as a
learning lesson in but last year was
very challenging and I hope it'll make
me a better man we seem happy you seem
healthy you seem like you're in a better
place like what would you use like what
kind of words would you use to describe
this place that you're in right now
would you say emotionally yes I'm very
healthy emotionally stable yeah okay
yeah and then just and just a lot more
in tune yes myself and my feelings like
there was some so many things happening
last year so many different feelings I
at times I didn't really want to deal
with them mm-hmm and but that's the one
thing that I in 2018 I find very very
instrumental moving forward is that I
whether they're good it's good to take
them on head-on yeah exactly
um I want to talk about the eating
disorder a little bit because that was a
big revelation because I know that even
two years ago and we talked you talked
about your weight and people having this
misconception because you were skinny
but we never really got into that and I
had no idea did you always know that you
had an eating disorder was that
something that you discovered through
the way that you were living your life
and going on the doctors no matter how
did that no I actually discovered it
when I was 19 I went to the doctor and
got an endoscopy done in there
a hiatal hernia which is a stress
condition right and makes you you know
not hungry so but yeah the hiatal hernia
thing was definitely something that
attributed to me getting really skinny
and it was just it was a really tough
time you know I felt like I wasn't
comfortable looking at myself in a
mirror didn't feel attractive to myself
in any way shape or form and so I don't
think I you know could really accept it
from anybody else even relationships out
of doing stuff like that so do you think
that that contributed to the demise of
some of your past relationships probably
yeah maybe a little bit yeah you have
that self-love I didn't and I was
dealing with stresses and putting up
with stuff that I probably wouldn't do
anymore yeah so um talking how do you I
guess plan on keeping a healthy body
image moving forward I know that's
probably a vague question no it's it's a
good question I would say really just
not getting in my head and staying out
of it staying out of like you know
getting stressed out or letting people
dumb opinions and what they have to say
affect me when they really have no idea
what's going on in my life you know what
about going on tour I feel like tour it
kicks off February 22nd it's got to be
hard to be on the road and you're in a
different city every night it's got to
be a little bit exhausting are you
worried about that like what's the plan
to to stay healthy well I'm not really a
big party or anyway so I'm I'm gonna be
resting I got a sing yeah so I want to
sound really good and that's my focus my
focus is not to go out on the road and
to be like this crazy wild bad-boy
partying and you know doing all that
crazy no it's not it's yeah my my goal
is to go out there and to be at my
absolute best and when I did things like
Broadway like they taught me like sleep
is one of the most important things for
a singer so Larry I don't want to sound
terrible so I want to sleep that's more
important to me
and being on this stage and you know
doing my best up there that's what I'm
out there to do not any other crazy
shenanigans you know shenanigans what
does that night on Aaron Carter's tour
bus look like I sleep as much yeah it's
it's crazy I'm like a bear in the winter
on to her I'm sleeping everywhere I can
all the time so it's a lot you know
traveling and being up and I don't know
I'm an insomniac too so I'll stay up
like yeah just making music okay that's
fair I wasn't asking because you told us
in December you still smoke weed yeah
still have let's go smoke weed so that's
not really being sober
that's not then right no I mean maybe
not
no I when I went through the treatment
process I told everybody there I'm like
when I leave I'm gonna be smoking weed
still oh and why because I like to know
can we just do I find it to be a very
peaceful Zen thing and spiritual and so
it's still is altering your state of
mind though do you worry about that that
it's a gateway to other things that it's
gonna mess with you man well that's
that's what they say but I mean I don't
know I'm not gonna let that happen
I'm just not gonna let that happen I
have so how do you make sure that's not
gonna happen
how do I don't know I am but it's the
truth like like I like to keep it real
which I appreciate I think I could have
lied you know but why do that what does
that do for me I know I just I've known
for a while now and I want you to be on
this like healthy path and not to say
that weed is a horrible thing but to do
it every day
oops I'm doing it are you doing it every
day you told us you told us in December
that it's a ritual yeah it's a ritual so
not every day not every day but it's
pretty much a ritual how much money do
you spend on weed a year oh my god I get
all my weed for free so I don't believe
you you don't know why you get
you grew online yes I grow it is my
stress being how much you spent on weed
here what would you say like more or
less than 25,000 an arm and a leg
that's a lot of no I don't know give me
a guess just a number guess yes yes oh
my god I never calculated it I don't
know maybe 10 grand a year probably a
lot of money for a good cause though how
much are you drinking none away
completely I was never I was never a
drinker okay never know you said that
you drink some roses hey sometimes
sometimes why yeah well I mean like oh
my god I was never yeah exactly I was
never somebody who like drank themselves
to like getting blackout drunk and never
ever ever ever ever
what about prescription meds No so
you've cut all those out all of them yep
everything stopped all that even after I
got out of treatment they had me on
certain things and I stopped all of it I
don't want to be on anything PTSD so
that's yeah and but I I feel like I
dealt with a lot of things and I have a
kind of a different you know mentality
when it comes to certain things and I
believe willpower is a very important
thing and you know with treatment
sometimes they don't believe in that so
I believe in the 12-step program and
given your your power away and stuff
like that so would you ever do that gave
it all up
good twist up no give give up we'd give
up everything I could yeah if I wanted
to so you just don't want to weed I'm
always gonna be I'm always gonna be an
endorser of I yeah okay thank you take a
few more cannabis cup antonym next year
I'm just kidding
[Laughter]
keeping it real what is your fave some
from the new album my favorite song I
have one you yeah yeah we told me first
what did he want to say yeah that one's
good
really yes number 5 yeah hmm I would say
I would actually say that one too I just
I just said the I refer to the label
really days ago yeah so you've good
taste in music yeah you have great days
is that gonna be a single it's gonna be
a single yeah
I think so okay I'm actually almost 100%
positive it will definitely be a single
have you shot any more music videos not
yet okay I'm gonna be working on it but
leaving for tour so it kind of makes it
a little difficult but I'm gonna gather
some footage I decided I'm gonna gather
some footage from the process of the
whole tour and put it together and make
it the music video because last year
when I was in a relationship the last
relationship I was in she was on the
road with me live you know this kind of
thing so and now I'm going back on the
road no she's not there so it could be a
cool you know cool thing to gather some
footage and make it very real and
personable in each city and you know yes
I'm still I still have sad moments like
where you know do you miss the ex I
might miss the idea of of the
relationship but at the same time there
were certain things like I don't like
about it
like I got it was to codependence yeah
codependent relationship so what
ultimately caused that breakup cuz you
guys seemed very much in love yeah
it was little things like little dumb
nagging types relationship stuff that it
wasn't anything that was like too
detrimental or anything but it was just
the course of their relationship I think
it just took its hole so
chance of a reconciliation I don't think
so you're like no way no I don't do that
no no I try to learn from my young
decisions that's mature Oh Kayla says
you look so good
do you go to therapy I was doing some
therapy when I got out of the treatment
center but I think you are yeah I'm not
why I don't know I just believe I don't
know maybe it's maybe it's because of
like like my family dynamic broke up and
then like once that happened there there
was always like members of the family
single just go to therapy go therapy so
it kind of has like this this negative
connotation to me mm-hmm so which I
think a lot of people have about therapy
but I think it's a good it's a good way
to talk about what's going on yeah I
just have a different belief I feel like
you know people and your family and
friends the like why can't you have
conversations with people and then help
you and them that regard too but then
they're buyers and there's like yeah
right I know coz can you go to Nick and
get super honest answers or therapy
together and work out you know guys I've
been in yeah well yeah Nick is a very
big believer in therapy and I'm not so
we're just you know a lot different a
little bit in that regard
why are you laughing I don't know you
make me smile oh that's nice oh david
says what is your biggest regret my
biggest regret yeah I'm probably putting
too much out there for people to see
last year I think we did we just yeah
just touched on that a little bit misty
says would you ever join Nick and the
Backstreet Boys in Vegas no I was
thinking I said no too quickly and then
I realized they didn't want to say no
okay no III do my own thing
yeah myself and the Backstreet Boys we
haven't really parts
with each other in a long time last time
we did anything together they randomly
showed up against what stars in the
front row so that was the last time that
you had a camaraderie moment with all
them hmm I didn't even know they were
coming
what that seems weird to me there's
weird things in this industry that I can
reveal we've lots of viewers come on I
know I just told you a good one that is
a good one
that's Nick didn't feel like he wasn't
gonna give you a heads up but you guys
are good today now though everything's
cool
yeah I mean there's a there's a little
distance in our relationship but it is
what it is like you know what was the
last thing you guys talked about if you
were to show us your text message I tell
you that it's pretty sensitive subject
the last good thing that we talked about
is that you know my brother was happy to
see that you know I'm doing good so so
that's nice so he offered his support
yeah more than just on Twitter the
conversations have been on Twitter wait
isn't it so stupid it's guys are
brothers yeah I actually was pretty
disappointed when he decided to tweet me
after I got arrested for an alleged DUI
right yeah it was like hey you know I'll
help you get you know help you throw you
know somewhere like kind of that's how
it fell and I was just like no that's
like what are you doing right don't
don't have that kind of relationship
with me
you got my number don't act like you
don't know my number yeah and if it's
that serious man DM me yeah okay that
works
I check them awkward but I check them he
checks them have you spent a lot of time
in the baby I've actually had some cool
cool moments yeah with with Odin he's
cool a little kid yeah I you wanting to
be a dad like sooner later is it I don't
know when it's right when I'm I had a
really really strong point in my life so
and I'm getting there okay so
no rush though I mean I have a lot of
expectations for myself to being a
really great place to do that yeah okay
but I'm getting there
I love that you came out as bisexual
pretty recently actually it was so nice
to see all the support of your fans the
LGBTQ community how is that to be so
embraced I mean it was it was it was
cool I mean I opened up about an
experience that happened when I was 17
years old
yeah and nothing was actually ever
happened with a guy after that and yeah
I just I wanted to be open about it and
honest that I can find men attractive
but I personally see myself being a
relationship with a woman you know okay
that's that's where I sit sit with that
so you don't senior music moving forward
to have different pronouns and then it
really can't because I haven't had those
experiences really so it was I was
really just touching on something that
happened when I was 17 and just wanted
to be open about that so which I think a
lot of people appreciate it I think what
people love so much about you is your
willingness to me so honest and open and
candid about I mean the booty sometimes
oh but not that no no that no that was
completely cool everyone was very
supportive I got a lot of love from the
LGBTQ community so it was nice it was
nothing crazy um
Kayla says who did you meet at the
airport in Seattle that inspired your
song Seattle Times my ex-girlfriend
Madelene patch she's on the road oh oh
yeah you guys dated yeah when when she
worked at Republic of Pi stop she met
her she was working up Republic of Pi
sorry three little red curls and I asked
her on a date and that was very
gentlemanlike with her how long did you
guys date for we dated for five six
months something like that and then we
stopped dating okay four yeah
and when you wrote a song about her I
did does she know that you wrote a song
she knows she knows it's about her yeah
what did she say about it she said that
songs written about me she's heard it oh
yeah she's hey did you send it to her
obviously because it's not out until
Friday yeah no she no she's heard it
yeah in person okay are you a fan of
Riverdale have you been watching I have
not been watching it it's really good
but I heard it's doing great and I'm
very happy for her yeah very happy she's
a very talented extremely talented
actress oh yeah nothing but love to her
changing the subject a little bit we
were talking about how he became famous
since you were 10 or when you were 10 if
you could take it all back and now be in
the spotlight at 30 like this is your
first album how do you think your life
would be different I have no clue how do
you think it would be different I think
a lot different it would be a lot
different there wouldn't be so many
preconceived notions yeah exactly I
think it'd be that's what I would think
there wouldn't nobody would know every
little detail about my life well how do
you think that effect that's my fault
yeah you sure a lot I do I talk too much
affected things who knows I probably
wouldn't have as much experience with
music as I do okay so yeah thing then
yeah definitely I mean cuz like
overnight like 15 was last time I
released an album and ever since then
I've been really just like studying
music and music and developing my own
music theory right so and that's why I
was so heavily involved in the creative
side of this project you know Purdue
producing on it as well as you know
writing heavily so yeah it's kind of
along that same line any question over
here 15-20 years of being the spotlight
that you've never been asked that you
wish somebody would have asked you by
now oh my gosh I think I've been of my
I've been asking I've been asked like
some crazy questions like I don't know
anything real like I wish I could talk
about this in an interview
maybe like what inspired me to want to
become a producer what inspires you to
want to become a producer what inspired
me you want to become a producer
probably people like Scott Storch mark
Batson dr. Dre and also wanting to prove
to people that I'm a real musician and
I'm not just some guy being thrown to
the studio being told what's the thing
any question that you never want to be
asked again I have quite a few of those
I'll make sure I'm gonna add it probably
by my ex-girlfriend we want to play a
little game with you it is called the
love down love down all questions about
love okay are you ready let's do it how
many times have you been in love I
really don't I think I might have been
like in lust and codependent and all
those things but not really truly in
love okay I'm surprised by that why well
I felt like you were almost gonna get
engaged last year yeah but that didn't
work out so I mean no it's a question
love have no masters why maybe because
my experience hasn't been the best the
outcome always is like you know
disappointment all right the part of
yourself that you love the most
we talked a lot about self-love probably
my goofy side if I have one no no maybe
you do yeah I keep for sure has a goofy
side I just feel like laughter and joy
and being silly not so like oh my god I
gotta get my ankles right like it's too
much like just be fun and have fun in
like who cares about you know being
Sue's taking yourself too seriously I'm
and as I get older I'm getting a little
bit more goofier so that's
good thanks mom my mom's a super goof
ball is she yeah I'm gonna do Instagram
live videos remember this one is
interesting have you ever are you ready
for this have you ever made love to your
own music oh no I'm a virgin
believe me no yes I have made love to
our candy stop no it was Howard be
shocked I put it in the hoop like spam
give us a straight answer they're all
laughing back there I swear that I'm
telling you the guys cuz that's weird
okay so know this song that you love the
most on your album oh I like them I
don't love any of them you don't have
any songs oh because they were about two
ex-girlfriends so you gotta get back in
the studio then I guess so actually no I
love champion it's about my father
there we go is that weird to play songs
over and over again that are about your
exes a little bit yeah I gotta think
about it sometimes it's been almost a
year since mother breakup for my last
relationship so I think like I'm healed
like it's not affecting me like I'm not
gonna like turn around like I already
did that couple times
Oh sometimes I wasn't even able to sing
the song so I just skipped to the next
one that but now you're in a different
place yes they're good yeah I'm good
okay I'm not hanging on don't worry let
go the tattoo you loved the most
the tattooin love the most and you were
telling me earlier gonna get one of them
removed yeah this one's going bye-bye
we show the camera let's get that
close-up wait the love is going it's
going
yeah don't worry I'm gonna film it too
if so everyone cause II mean
excruciating pain you want to remove it
well when I came up with the concept
love for the album I went and got a
tattooed on my neck but it was like
right at a time that I was going through
like a really bad breakup and I think I
did it out of like spider than some
stupid reason I don't know like I yeah
yeah something like that
and it's I mean it's what you see before
like when I had my interview with you I
had this right yeah it was like right
after that that was when it was shocking
so you know cuz I had not seen you with
it so I was like whoa but now I'm used
to it
now you say yeah but it's gonna go no
it's gonna hurt real bad to get that
taken off it is but you know it probably
won't hurt as bad as the relationship
what's your favorite my favorite I would
say my piano yeah I have to actually
though on my body surprises well this
one is my favorite because it depicts me
being a music music producer yeah and I
also played it by the way yes I directed
the video too so I was really happy
about that yeah you know that's my
ex-girlfriend I know I know
she was the backup dancer right yeah
yeah don't put your there or even your
girlfriends and you music videos
yeah we'll move forward how will you
cast your love interests in your music
videos viciously vicious you should get
Madeleine in one of them no it was a
decent idea yeah no I think I'm just
gonna be solo solo dolo
okay what type of love are you looking
for next that's a good question
committed patient real no just those
kind of dumb little things yeah even
though they don't they sound like just
like whatever but to me I don't know
what are you looking for in a
relationship well I I like that quote we
accept the love we think we deserve so
what do you think you deserve I'm not
gonna answer that question question oh
my gosh I think we all deserve to be
loved you know yeah truly genuinely
loved for the right reasons and now for
the wrong reasons so I think I've been
I've been loved for some of the wrong
reasons and that's not taking away from
anything stupid or like you know my
mistakes that I've made in relationships
but yeah it's hard it's really hard
being doing what I do being around so
long and in his industry and then trying
to be in a relationship it just sucks
you need some sort of applicant process
yeah I do someone understands like what
this industry is made of yeah and it's
made of like rumors lies preconceived
notions but you know it's a lot of a lot
of stuff like that like don't like I
don't want to be in a relationship with
somebody who goes and tries to figure me
out from googling me yeah like this is
it's it's just embarrassing and it's
it's not all like my you know that's
moments like it's not all my best
moments you know like the Internet is
it's its clickbait I'm used as clickbait
for negative drama things and like don't
think I'm not aware of that stuff I know
I'm playing your game to tow a hundred
percent you know I mean you know how it
all work I know how it works 23 years I
should know yeah and a lot of people
probably don't understand how it works
what's the worst headline that you've
ever read about yourself the worst
headline probably that like I had this
like love triangle with Hillary Lindsay
which was absolutely not true
it wasn't no I didn't you show up to one
of their premieres with the other one we
talked about yeah but that was different
come on you knew that was different you
reconcile things with Hillary yeah any
time I try to reconcile anything with
ex-girlfriends it doesn't go so well so
I just don't do that
don't do it what about Lindsay Lohan
would you ever reach back out to her for
what to make a mans like do you guys
ever talk would you know I think we were
cool after that like we had some some
moments like where we were cool right
yeah I brought her a biscuit one time a
biscuit like bread yeah you brought
Lindsay Lohan bread in what context she
was just really skinny randomly showed
up and felt like she needed a biscuit
yeah
you brought Lindsay up no we brought her
up how old were you when this happened I
was like four no I was like bored he you
were 14 and you brought her a biscuit
Punk what can I say I'm gonna start
bringing people biscuits yeah I mean
Popeyes only okay KFC has good ones too
no they don't what I don't know
chick-fil-a have you never been a pop
she's always like it's all this like
nice vegan exciting touch that okay
there you go I don't know I try to be I
can't um what do you love most about
being 30 hmm I would say that I made it
to 30
did you not think you're gonna make it
to 30 you know I think growing up in
this in the industry so young I just it
was a lot of life that I was
experiencing and for some reason I never
thought I would make it to be 30 years
old I don't know it wasn't like anything
crazy it was just like I just I didn't
know I didn't know that's very morbid
and depressing ya know and I thought
about that like at a really young age
yeah well how old are you and you
thought about that like 10 or 11 years
old super young I know it is it is
pretty yeah he's pretty weird I don't
know why I thought of that well I must
have watched like Chucky or something
that night
it's nothing scary have you had any
since you were like four or five with
your dad any near-death experiences
[Music]
really no scary moments no okay mm-hmm
not that I can think of okay if I think
about it you know oh my god I mean there
probably is a few moments I don't know
four-wheeler accidents dumb stuff okay
but nothing like substance abuse related
no no no no no okay
when was the last time that you were
completely substance free how old were
you
no need no alcohol no last year you know
it was a few months where I wasn't
smoking weed or anything like that I saw
when you were in the treatment center
and not being as remiss not to you okay
so you're able to do it easily
yeah okay hazily I'm not addicted to
weed yeah okay okay I worry about you
before we wrap up this is the last one
what do you love most about your album
what do I love most about the album now
after 15 years and being denied by a lot
of people that I was able to come back
out with a body of work that I'm very
proud of
and that might touch on subjects that at
times maybe I have like them you know
sad moments you know singing them but
what makes you the saddest what makes me
the saddest yeah probably probably when
I sing my song don't say goodbye because
like I didn't want to say goodbye but I
had to so sucks but yeah that sounds
heart-wrenching for me don't you do you
still get emotional singing them yeah I
mean I'm not to the point where I'm like
crying anymore but I mean there are some
heavy emotions that are tied to these
songs and I you know Valentine's Day you
know stuff like that that is happening
like you know I don't have Valentine
that's that's fine there's people out
there that don't either but you know I
think that this song is or not that song
this album is a good good project and
good story for people to hear if they're
going through tough things and
relationships maybe they could play it
to their significant other and get get
out of it what I couldn't it's
interesting because the lyrics are all
about love and love lost but the beats
are really upbeat yeah they're contrary
to each other with that intention well
it's I think the juxtaposition in the
whole each song is is incredible my
cocoa producer night lingua and we
worked really hard on creating a sound
that is like because he's from Germany
and I'm from you know like Florida so I
I listen to a lot more like trap music
and stuff so I take my elements of like
what I learned and then he takes the EDM
elements and we put them together and
you know that's what that's what you get
so each song is kind of like it's just
like it goes up and down and up and down
counts a strike on your ride and each
each song has like a cool like a little
break in it so yeah you can just vibe to
the music for a little bit song totally
when was the last time you cried you
keep mentioning crying about what about
my ex for about two minutes what
triggered that looking up into the stars
and it just made you sad my stomach's
really
yes no I was looking like I was looking
at the stars and like the clouds and I
got emotional thinking that you know
we're under the same stars and clouds so
you don't reach out to her no don't send
those I don't X text no no X Dexter hey
I wonder if she's gonna watch this and
be like Oh probably not no problem
well the all part definitely not okay
alright um and last fan question two of
them dave says any plans for a book
mm-hmm and who would put who would play
you in a movie about your life
I like that question 15 yeah I don't
know about that one but the book plan
that is something that my team and I
have been talking about doing a book and
really getting in depth though and not
just making it some you know tell-all or
something something like that okay
I think my experiences can teach a lot
of people a lot of things about this
industry and growing up and there's a
lot of young kids that like are being
put into this industry and I see it and
I wanted I just desperately like want to
find ways to protect them right and
because I I grew up you know with
parents that didn't do the best job
managing you know monies and finances
and
and even raising their kids and teaching
them the right right from wrong and you
know so but that's also a good thing
about my 20s is that I learned a lot of
things a little bit later in life
because of the industry that I had
growing up so it's interesting that you
said that and I know we're gonna wrap up
but we had someone here who used to be
on Disney Channel and he said he thinks
it should be mandatory for kids on
Disney or Nickelodeon to have group
therapy sessions I thought that was
interesting do you think that would have
helped you and some sort of even though
I don't really necessarily believe in
there
definitely wouldn't condone that yeah I
would definitely support that one of my
things that I wanted to do in one of the
things I'm still striving to do is to
create a new law because Paul Peterson
created the Coogan law that puts 15% of
kids money into a block trust account
before they turn 18 but there there are
some faults in that because you can't
like you just turn 18 you've got all
this money like what are you gonna do
you're gonna you're gonna submit you
exactly so I really want to try to
recreate a new law called the Carter law
and that it it makes kids have to go
through business schooling's and that
they get their money in increments
throughout a 10-year period after they
turn 18 so that they actually learned
how to manage their own finances and
they don't blow through it and they're
like oh I'm so grateful that 10 years
later I had you know a third of my trust
account still waiting for me after I
learned more about life experiences I
love that idea have you done research to
make that happen I actually met with
Paul Peterson it was a while ago but um
it's it's gonna be a tough thing to do
but um that's one of my goals and one of
the things I want to leave as my
legacies is that I went through certain
experiences and then I created this this
law protecting kids from themselves
essentially and from you know your lack
of experience what is the silliest thing
that you purchased right when you turned
18 really like I wish I wouldn't have
done that I'm I totally love everything
I got no regrets actually no there's
there's one regret that I bought like
thirty Pharrell Williams ice cream shoes
like I bought all of them and now I
don't even know where any of them are 30
30 different colors everything I scream
shoes they had like ice cream and all
kinds of weird stuff it was Pharrell
shoes that came out I hope for L knows
that you are such a loyal fan I've got
some of my trust fund there bud yeah and
then really fast Maria says will you be
my Valentine yes cuz I have none I have
no Valentine well actually no no do you
you're like damning type thing here
going on well what we're gonna do in a
few minutes if you had to e t--'s
Instagram is we're actually gonna have
in on their accepting them so go in
there Maria and let's meet in person
we'll see how this works give us like
five minutes to set that up and go get
his album on Friday it's called love
it's good it's really good you should
feel very proud of it thank you I am
very proud of it yes go get it
shameless promotion promotion yeah any
last words I love you guys alright we'll
see you guys next time make sure you
keep up with him keep up with 18 make
sure you like our YouTube page our
Facebook page
all that good stuff and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
you